die wichtigste frage die sich die
deutschen momentan stellen ist natürlich
urlaub in diesem jahr nur in deutschland
ja oder nein
na ja ich glaube schon dass das auch in
europa zumindest möglich sein sollte
denn der virus macht ja vor den grenzen
ich halt also insofern kommt das glaube
ich mehr auf die regionen an auf die
sicherheit an und geben sicherheit
sichergestellt werden kann also insofern
glaube ich dass ist schon region in
europa gibt wie zum beispiel mallorca
wie zum beispiel kroatien wie zb auch
die griechischen inseln wo es ja sehr
wenige fälle gab auch die kanarien
gehören sicher dazu da kann man
sicherlich sehr sicher urlaub machen
also insofern gehe ich davon aus dass
das zumindest in europa in diesem jahr
auch möglich sein wird jetzt zwei
kreuzfahrtfans auch bei uns in der
sendung die ihnen gerne eine persönliche
frage stellen würden erneut vielleicht
sie als erstes ja hallo ist unsere reise
oder am 15
im dritten abgesagt und ja es wurde am
drittens auch zugesagt von tui cruises
dass der reisepreis erstattet wird
das ist nun aber mittlerweile acht
wochen her und auf fragen per mail oder
so bekommt man aktuell gar keine infos
mehr die frage ist wann wird
haben sie die frage hier noch mal
wiederholen die frage ich habe die frage
schon verstärken also nicht genau aber
ich habe verstanden es gibt ist eine
reise abgesagt worden und es ist jetzt
die frage was passiert mit dem
reisepreis das ist tatsächlich eine sehr
offene frage
es wurde ja in den corona kabinett in
deutschland beschlossen das ist eine
deutsche lösung geben soll wo es auch
für die bunten anreize geben soll um
eben tatsächlich zukünftig weiter im
urlaub machen zu können das ist vor
allem deshalb wichtig weil ja die
anzahlung in ein system vor allem auf
die reisebüros ausgesprochen schwierig
sind wenn man die also rückerstatten
muss hier gibt es in deutschland eine
entscheidung die allerdings in europa
derzeit noch strittig ist allerdings ist
es auch so dass wir jetzt bald eben die
entscheidung noch offen sind angefangen
haben zu einem teil muss man sagen weil
das natürlich wahnsinnig wieder anträge
sind auch die rückerstattungen
vorzunehmen freigabe von spaß hier auch
sie haben eine frage an herrn müssen ja
wir sind allerdings mit der aida gereist
und haben nach achteinhalb wochen den
vollen reisepreis unserer abgebrochenen
reise erstattet bekommen insoweit sind
wir jetzt sehr zufrieden aber die
nächste reise steht an für september wir
haben die griechischen inseln geplant
ich hoffe zuversichtlich dass dieser
reise stattfinden wird
ich glaube das ist eine gute frage
bis september ist dann noch eine sehr
lange zeit es gibt jetzt eine globale
reisewarnung derzeit noch die wir
allerdings bis zum 14
juni die wir allerdings für nicht
sachgerecht gehalten
wir glauben dass es durchaus eben auch
hier möglichkeiten geben sollte selektiv
da wo ist die sicherheit zu reisen
wie gesagt unsere hotels in spanien auch
in griechenland bereiten sich auf die
villa bevor
bei den kreuzfahrten wird das
möglicherweise dann noch ein bisschen
länger dauern
wir gehen davon aus dass wir zumindest
anfänglich schiffe bei einigen die
deutschen helfen legen und
möglicherweise am anfang eben auch nur
mit einem drittel oder mit 40 prozent
der kapazität fahren auch hier müssen
wir natürlich sicherheit gewährleisten
können und auch in sicherung und eben
für die gesundheit sicheren betrieb
gewährleisten können wie gesagt
september ist noch ein stückchen hin
ich befürchte sag ich mal da gibt es
derzeit noch wirklich keine garantie
weder in die eine noch in die andere
richtung
wir wollen etwas bei dem thema noch
bleiben natürlich wurden alle bereiche
der reisegesellschaft jetzt getroffen
von dieser krise aber würden sie sagen
dass die kreuzfahrt ganz besonders hart
betroffen worden ist weiß jetzt immer
wieder die geschichten gab von den
vielen corona kreuzfahrtschiffen
ich glaube wenn man wenn man eine
gewichtung macht ich meine grundsätzlich
muss man sagen heute ist es ja so
dadurch dass hier ein globaler
reisewarnung karten auch die regelungen
des social distance sinkt im konnte man
derzeit ja gar nicht verreisen und
deshalb ist die gesamte touristische
branche auch hier derzeit mit einem
umsatz von null also ohne umsatz
jetzt kommen ja die lockerungen und
richtig ist besonders dort wo große
investitionen geleistet sind wie zum
beispiel der kreuzberg aber auch zb im
flugbetrieb
sind natürlich die schäden besonders
groß und jede woche die man keinen
urlaub machen kann und keinen urlaub
anbieten kann wird natürlich schon zu
dem problem das gilt vor allen dingen
auch muss man sagen neben der kreuzfahrt
und im flug auch für die südeuropäischen
länder dort ist natürlich der anteil am
bruttosozialprodukt noch viel höher der
anteil an den arbeitsplätzen die an dem
tourismus erkannt noch viel höher
deshalb gibt es auch die enormen
anstrengungen in griechenland spanien
zum beispiel um eben auch einen sicheren
urlaub gewährleisten zu können und wir
als reiseveranstalter haben natürlich
auch die verantwortung dafür dass das
seriös und gut wie möglich ist sie haben
gerade gesagt der umsatz nicht gerade
bei null muss man also sagen tui wäre
ohne steuergelder jetzt pleite
naja ich es schon so dass wir dass wir
wenn wir keine staatshilfe hätten wäre
das eine sehr schwierige situation denn
die kosten gehen ja weiter und auch
dieses recht nicht werbens eu gehört zum
teil müssen eben heute schon und wir
haben heute auch schon die reisepreise
gestartet also insofern wäre das ohne an
den staatlichen kredit es ist ja ein
kredit der auch zurückgezahlt werden
muss mit zinsen also man bekommt ja
nichts geschenkt aber ohne diese
überbrückung wer das für die thuine sehr
schwierige situation
also kann man eigentlich sein der
deutsche steuerzahler hat den
pauschalurlaub gerettet na ja ich würde
es so sagen letztendlich das ist ein
kredit nicht also insofern wir kriegen
kein geld vom steuerzahler dass er nicht
zurück bekommen sondern das bekommt er
zurück mit zinsen das ist für die für
die branche und für viele in der branche
das gilt für die reisebüros aber
natürlich auch für alle anderen im
regelfall sind dass kredite und etwas
was man zurückzahlen muss das heißt also
ist würde ich sagen für uns das dicke
ende kommt denn das geld ist ja nicht
geschenkt sondern das bild an den staat
zurück die
staatliche kredit bank die zinsen und
zinseszinsen wenn sie jetzt in die
zukunft blicken denken sie dass urlaub
nie wieder so aussehen wird wie vor
corona na ja also ich glaube nie wieder
das würde ich glaube ich nicht sagen
anfänglich ist es klar zumindest bis es
einen impfstoff oder medikamente gibt
wird man schon anders urlaub machen und
darauf bereiten wir uns ja auch vor das
andere ist natürlich schon wenn man die
buchung der zukunft sieht also die
buchung zum beispiel jetzt für das
nächste jahr
sie sind noch sehr wenig weil es
natürlich noch sehr viel ist aber sie
sind heute schon auch etwa dem doppelten
niveau von dem was man im normalen ja
erwarten würde also ich gehe auch davon
aus dass ist schon nachholeffekt geben
wird weil die menschen wollen in urlaub
fahren und auch zu recht ist urlaub für
die allermeisten das wichtigste in einem
jahr also die menschen werden darauf
nicht verzichten es gibt keine anzeichen
dafür
eine letzte nachfrage dazu noch wenn sie
sagen jetzt in kommender zeit wird
urlaub trotzdem anders aussehen wie muss
man sich das vorstellen dass puls dann
weiter nicht benutzbar sind dass es kein
befehl mehr gibt weil man sich dort
trifft was denken sie sind konkrete
maßnahmen mundschutz in hotels worauf
muss man sich jetzt einstellen
na ja ich glaube schon dass man
versuchen muss eben die regeln dieses
heute gibt auch weiter einzuhalten
also wenn man es war sport macht wird
man versuchen eben möglich sport zu
machen wo es eben nicht mannschaftssport
gibt es also sportarten gibt wenn man wo
man sie 15 19 auch welt wichtig ist auch
in den hotels wie sie schon sagen gefäß
wird's erst mal nicht geben sondern es
muss bedienungen geben
auch das thema mundschutz spielt noch
alle aus unserer sicht auch wenn man
sich das im flugzeug anguckt dann wird
es strenge hygiene standards geben
also insofern ein bisschen müssen alle
mithelfen aber trotzdem bleibt es dabei
es muss natürlich schon genese gelten
wie machen wir jetzt den urlaub wenn
möglich nur dass er sicher ist und statt
jetzt schon zu sagen wir machen nicht
möglich ich glaube das ist auch ganz
wichtig man sieht das auch ganz gut dass
wir jetzt schon ermöglichen also die
ersten hotels öffnen wir ja schon in
deutschland hinter jetzt mitte mai ab
mitte mai das sieht man die buchung sind
natürlich sehr hoch und der bedarf ist
sehr hoch also insofern glaube ich dass
man darüber nachdenken sollte wie man
den urlaub sicher möglich macht ich
glaube dass im interesse der kunden auch
im interesse der